[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I'm Amrit Sanjeev
for the Developer Show.
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
The final API 28 Emulator image
for Wear OS is now available.
Highlights of API 28 include
a new notification stream,
App Standby Buckets, and more.
Take a look at the post
linked in the description
below for the details
and to get started.
Access to traditional apps with
secure LDAP from cloud identity
is now generally available.
Lots of details and link to
get started are on the post.
The Associate Cloud
Engineer certification
helps organizations
identify individuals
who can demonstrate
a solid working
knowledge of Google Cloud
products and technologies.
And it's now
available in German.
To learn more about the
certification and to get
started, check out the post.
We recently collaborated
with Microchip
on the AVR-IoT WG
development board.
It is the first 8-bit
microcontroller development
board connected to the
Google Cloud platform.
It will help lower
the barrier to entry
to develop IoT solutions across
cost, security, and float
connectivity.
Details and a photo of
the board are on the post.
In Firebase
Performance Monitoring,
you can now dig deeper into an
individual session of a trace.
This will allow you to see
attributes and events that
happened leading to
a performance issue.
Head over to the post for
the three new categories
of information and
some screenshots.
Also in Firebase is a redesign
notification dashboard
which supports much more
sophisticated and powerful
notification campaigns.
More details and
screenshots are in the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Amrit Sanjeev for
the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week.
OK?
Good?
[MUSIC PLAYING]